desde hace 63 años tanto actores como
escritores en Hollywood no se ponían de
acuerdo en una huelga conjunta
11.500 escritores entraron en huelga en
mayo y ahora 160.000 actores entran en
huelga también y pues las consecuencias
van a ser bastante grandes primero
Empezando por que la huelga no se no se
permitirá que actores que hacen parte
del sindicato
hagan parte de los eventos de promoción
y de publicidad de sus películas de
películas Como por ejemplo visión
imposible o Barbie Pues los actores de
estas películas no podrán participar en
estos eventos de publicidad y el
lanzamiento de estas películas que han
generado tanta tanto ruido recientemente
también se dice que se va a aplazar
posiblemente los premios emmy que se
iban a celebrar este verano posiblemente
pues entonces aplazada para el otoño
también celebrado pues afectada
obviamente toda la industria y la
economía local en Los Ángeles todas las
personas que dependen de la Industria
del cine y de la televisión tendrán que
pues empezar a buscar nuevas formas de
financiarse para sobrevivir estas
próximas semanas o meses en la
negociación una negociación que además
Pues según Fuentes anónimas citadas por
medios estadounidenses no se sabe
todavía cuándo volverán a sentarse a la
mesa de negociación incluso estos medios
nacionales de Guardián entre otros Pues
citaban que pues las productoras de cine
de televisión están bastante reacias a
los puntos que están exigiendo los
artistas Y es que pues hay que Resaltar
que artistas de la talla de
Jennifer Lawrence han apoyado estos
160.000 artistas que están en huelga en
este momento y
que pues a futuro no parece haber una
negociación O al menos un diálogo para
tratar de llegar a un acuerdo